So we have seen our Function Inlining quiz.
Now let's talk about its solution. After scheduling, how many cycles?
Well, let's see first what the scheduling will do. We have a load.
We have to do it before the call. And after the call we can do the store.
So really scheduling can do nothing here. Here we need to do the multiplication.
And then, the ADD depends on it. And then, we can only return. So really there
is nothing scheduling can do here. So really we just need to figure out for
this sequence of instructions. How many cycles does it take to do it?
One way of doing that would be to say that the load begins in the first cycle.
In the second cycle it's still going on. So, we can use the result in
the third cycle. In the second cycle, however, we can do the call. The call also
takes two cycles, so we're really can execute this instruction in cycle four.
At that time, A0 is available. The multiplication takes three cycles. So
in cycles four, five, and six, the multiplication is happening. And
only cycle seven can we do this because it's using the result of
this instruction. We can build a return immediately afterwards. So
return now is happening in cycles eight and nine. And finally in cycle ten we
are back here. And then the store of course takes only one cycle, so
really after ten cycles we are done. Now let us see what the inlining will do.
What it will do is it will simply take these two instructions and
replace the call with them. Now let's see, can we do some scheduling around it?
We need to load A0. Then we're going to use it in multiplication.
Then we are going to use it in the addition. And
then, we are going to use the result on it in the store. So again,
scheduling is going to help us here. However, we have eliminated the call and
the return. So now what happens is we have the load begins in cycle one.
Next, we will try to do the multiplication but we can only do it in cycle three.
Because the load needs to produce the value for two cycles in cycles one and
two before we can use it. Next, we have the multiplication happening in
cycles three, four and five. So we can only do this in cycle six.
The add only takes one cycle. And the store can then happen in cycle seven. And
that's when it finishes. So after inlining and scheduling, we have reduced this
to seven cycles, mainly by eliminating the call and the return.